your first concert was Van Halen yeah I
I mean when I saw Van Halen in 84 I was
12 and they were my favorite band and I
cried you did yeah cuz Eddie was so it's
like his guitar playing came from a
different place like he reinvented how
to play guitar but they also wrote great
songs and I think that the that's the
main thing I I took away from Van Halen
is the songs were just so great
did you ever get to meet Eddie Van Halen
did you um hang with him at all yeah did
one time it was right when um uh Van
Halen got back together with David Lee
Roth me and a bunch of friends got on a
plane and we went to go see him in
Kansas City because we didn't want to do
it in California because we knew it was
going to be a show so we um it just
seemed like it was you know a lot of
people were there hobnobbing and it was
like you know a lot more celebrity and
rock stars and things like that
backstage so like was like let's go
somewhere where like it's like in the
heart of like where Rock fans are so we
went we went to the Midwest to go see
him play and it was they were incredible
and what was that like for you when you
met Eddie Van Halen it was kind of an
emotional thing it was you know first we
went back and I met Wolfie and who was
super cool and then they were like do
you want to meet Eddie and I was like oh
my God and so he's back there and he's
got his guitar on he's plugged in and
he's just it's like he's talking to me
and shredding at the same time and I was
just like oh my God and then like I and
and I don't know if anybody really knows
this but the size of his hands are
gigantic like no one yeah and I grabbed
his hands and I looked at them I was
like dude your hands are so he's like oh
I got arthritis now and blah blah blah
and then like this like really insane
thing happened where he kind of started
crying like and he looked at me and he
put his hand behind my neck like this
and he goes he's like you're the only
one that understands me and wow and he
was just had tears coming down his eyes
and and I was like you know I was like
and I didn't really know what to say I
was like man you have no idea like how
much you've meant to you know me as a as
a musician and as a as a a songwriter I
was like it's all about that he's like
like people think I'm you know I'm an
alien because the way I play and I'm
like it's all about your songs and he
goes exactly exactly and and then I it
was this really kind of heavy experience
and then the crazy thing is it was this
really sweet thing that happened is Wolf
Gang came in and Eddie's shredding and
he's going Dad Dad Dad and he was like
going what and he's like we have to tune
so they both had their guitar and bass
they weren't using a tuner they they go
and then he and then Eddie said the
coolest thing that you could it was like
a fatherson moment he goes do you want
to tune to me or do you want me to tune
to you and I was just like that kind of
bond that a father and son had as
musicians I thought was just like this
it always stuck with me as this
beautiful thing then we went back out
and watched in the crowd and like it was
just like a phenomenal
show